I back some little one Mike thank you
quite I'll take action final round
please pictures up sleet it and roll
sound that's me calling camera let me
know my name is michael joseph i am
playing moh Langley in deadly reunions
I'm also associate producer on this
project as well no need to see what they
say all right all right we've got about
this project since about october2013 no
excuse me 2014 I was approached as both
as a producer and as an actor so I'm
gonna see them before he starts to the
stove yeah there's no worries crossing
caring they're carrying a bunch of
bloody meat man okay so so basically i
got my QB they would be walking across
the doorway then i would come very well
you walk with everybody i walk into
everything else yeah okay Michael how
often are you in a production where you
have dual roles where your actor
producer executive producer more often
than not maybe like 20 or 30 percent of
the time lately were you always with
that line set or did that progress once
you start of seeing this is a way to get
booked and be a part of something I mean
I have it I would just go for business
so i think that helped but yes I
definitely like the behind the scenes
and piecing everything together as well
as being out in front and performing as
well how many other actors in la do you
see with that similar mind secular I
know we talked to Baron about sort of
the half artist half entrepreneur not
that many most actors are at home behind
the computers waiting for somebody to
come knock on their door to give them a
job most people don't work that hard I
don't think the most people are some
people are more dedicated than others
but some people just don't understand
that you have to provide your own work
you know in a lot of cases when one
project is done nobody's waiting for you
at the end of that project to give you
another job maybe and sometimes they are
you know but you have to continue to
fight so when you when you did go to
school for business what are some of
those takeaways that you've applied your
acting career work ethic but I think my
work ethic came from my parents my dad
was an entrepreneur so I always have
been that kind of entrepreneurial mind
state I mean as far as what I learned in
school I went to I studied marketing you
know I work in event marketing
specifically and in contract marketing
so it's I'm always one project to the
next so I learned a lot of that from
business like having to always provide
my next job once one job was over I had
to figure out what I was going to do
this you know wasn't an employee of
anyone but myself and I was the only one
that was providing the next paycheck for
me and acting is very much like that
entertainment is very much like that
from witnessing your father with his
businesses what is the entrepreneurial
mindset what is that mindset you said
you learned that sort of not being
complacent working hard being being
passionate about what you do in really
doing what you love and also knowing
that when one thing ends you've got to
be the one to launch right that's what
the hard work comes in you know and
always thinking about what the next step
is
thinking outside the box being focused
on what am I going to do after this is
over this is a bit of last forever you
know versus like working maybe in
corporate America when you have a job
salary then you just kind of punching
the class did you audition for this role
hey Baron see my work so I guess yeah
but technically no this right here micah
is a great guy he's my producer partner
and we actually met online for another
project which did not happen which may
be about six years ago no additional we
kind of like we connected through our
mutual friend Detroit farmer maybe like
three or four years ago so it's been a
great ride and I'm gonna ride and you
have to hold these guys sit I am I love
your beats yes but I got picture baked I
agree get out of here alive let's do
this god yes okay